never thought i'd say this cardinal
debut of john lester this is what
lester's going to do he's going to try
to paint corners he's not going to
attack these hitters he's going to work
in and out and you see him trying to get
ozzie to expand
and lester lost him a little off walk
for all bees and the braves offense goes
to work here at the first inning here's
jorge soler
and this one is smoke toward left center
field that ball is near the bullpen that
ball is gone
jorge solaire with a lightning bolt
gotta touch first first there we go
it's two nothing atlanta here in the
opening inning at busch stadium
you heard brian schnitker say he loves
this lineup
well you can't do anything but love this
start for atlanta well i was talking to
snit this morning chip and he was
talking about solera and said at first
you know i was going to kind of play him
against lefties for the most part has
been hammering but he said he's been
swinging the bat so well
such a power hitter that look right here
off right off the bat
well here's freddie 2 nothing atlanta
before the seats are even worn
and freddie right back where it came
from lester has yet to retire a braves
hitter yeah the braves are all over them
right now they've taken good swings when
the ball has been in the zone and
leicester back to the stretch with
red hot austin riley coming up
riley on the ground that's going to
sneak through for another hit
freddy around second he's on his way to
third
four straight braves have reached in the
opening inning first and third no one
out for dansy swanson two on pitch
smoked into center field that's down for
a hit that's going to score freeman
riley will stop at second
five straight braves have reached rbi
single for dansby it's three to nothing
hitters count pretty ball pitch on the
way from leicester
outside ball four load them up for junk
a little pop into shallow left that's
gonna drop for a hit
station to station are the braves a
blooper for jack peterson with two
strikes and atlanta does get a fourth
run
and still nobody out
bases loaded for kevin smith
on the ground that should be two
and it is but the braves will get
another run dansby swanson scores
that makes it five nothing and every
pitcher will tell you
when they get to hit before they throw a
pitch you're having a good night they
got a tough ombre tonight max freed who
has you see his last three starts what
he's done one and two with a 2.84 2-2 on
the way swung on and missed strike three
able to get him with a curveball dylan
carlson two hits shy of 100 for the
season the o2 pitch
put in play by carlson diving stop at
third austin reilly and carlson has hit
number 99 on the year max has his sign
the 3-2
struck him out
and you know what john lester is saying
why didn't i get that pitch in the top
of the first
and a swing and a miss is john lester
has his first cardinal strikeout
a little vintage john lester right here
just in and out up and down
good hard fast ball the way now he
greets freddie freeman who singled and
scored the third atlanta run in the
first inning
pitch a rocket deep to right down the
line towards the pole
homerun
freddie freeman drilled it down the line
and just did keep it fair and he will
round the bags for the 24th time this
year
[Applause]
rbi number 60 for freddy freeman
six nothing braves watch him pull his
hands out
right inside the line
fourth whole time on the hits list in st
louis history and not far behind rogers
hornsby
and yachty lines it out to left and that
ball is down o'neill will stop at second
base harrison bader batting 286
strike three right down broadway
couldn't pull the trigger
third strike out for three
doubles a triple three home runs and
there's a strikeout for leicester his
second of the night as we head to the
top of the fourth inning it'll be freed
albies and solaire for atlanta here in
the fourth
frayed with a base hit
jorge solaire two rhino homer back in
ending number one
3-2 pitch
and he got him
catches the bottom of the strike zone
strikeout number three for lester it's
always the knock on guys that come from
denver as he swung at that ball in the
dirt and is frustrated seven straight
for freed
there's tyler o'neal
and that's a base hit into left field
for tyler o'neill in a 10 pitch about
one of max's best sequences in the game
came when bader was up last time up now
the 2-2 pitch
swaying in a miss that will take care of
the cardinals five strikeouts for max
frady's through four with a shutout
freddie freeman is two for two with a
home run tonight as freddie shoots one
into center field he's three for three
freddie loves hitting in saint louis
he's continued that great work tonight
with a perfect night at the plate
adam duvall
has walked and struck out
and he struck him out
four strikeouts tonight for john lester
and his cardinals debut six nothing
midway through five max has had a good
fastball tonight and he has used it john
lester
first game in a cardinal uniform and i
believe he is rung up yes indeed dylan
carlson strikes out one away from max
and arenado chased the ball in the dirt
that'll be corralled by kevin smith and
max fried finishes with seven strikeouts
through six shot out innings what a
night
in san gabriel california love that
high fly ball into deep right center
and a one hopper
over the wall ground rule double and one
of the bright spots for the cardinals in
this ball game tonight has been tyler
o'neil he has a walk
vader first pitch swinging
and it gets mixed up between riley and
swanson
see austin riley trying to cut it off
and that might have been the only way
they get vader
hit 98 to 100 even with all that mileage
there's some mileage on that ball duvall
to left and it's caught
nice play tyler o'neal up against the
wall and left
good play
it's a nice job right at the end just
jumping up
i know that wall is to hurt
really good play by tyler o'neill
a bright spot tyler o'neill
and what has been a dismal night for the
cardinals the 1-2 pitch
and a base hit big night for tyler
o'neill on base four times
and three for three
two singles and a double giadia molina
single to left fly to left and grounded
out to third the o2 pitch
and molina base head into right field
o'neal will score
and the criminals get on the board with
two outs
in the bottom of the ninth they break
up the
shutout for atlanta
excellent baseball man
and that'll do it braves win it 6-1 is
your final score great start to the
series
jeff you score five in the first you
ought to win they did exactly that huge
night for freddie freeman he had three
more hits austin reilly had two they got
five off john lester and never looked
back